c'est ici au lycée agricole et horticole
de saint germain en laye que sont formés
les futurs paysagistes fleuriste ou
scientifique bio écologiques
aujourd'hui il ouvre ses portes à des
représentants de six pays différents
dans le cadre d'un projet erasmus
accueillis par la maison de l'europe des
yvelines les butineurs aucun échange un
petit peu ce que font les uns et les
autres dans leurs pays respectifs
parce qu'on sait très bien le problème
partout en europe c'est la
désertification du milieu rural que les
jeunes partent et qui ils vont aller
dans les villes et va plus être
agriculteur et veulent plus s'installer
c'était de pouvoir les orienter par
rapport à nos problématiques qu'on peut
avoir nous sur sur l'île de france et
peut-être ta façon plus globale en
france sur le circuit court comment
interagir avec notre nos consommateurs
délégation allemande grec polonaises et
suédoises ont participé à cette première
rencontre transnationales le projet riz
dit souhaite promouvoir la citoyenneté
active dans les zones rurales
une série de visites étaient prévues
dans les yvelines pendant plusieurs
jours c'était vraiment intéressant qu'à
saint germain et cette région de
versailles sont à côté de paris a donc
c'est plus comme une banlieue mais qui
reste très rural quand on compare à la
pologne
c'est vraiment très différent les
distances entre chaque village aux
grandes villes sont bien plus grandes
match à 24 participants ont pu découvrir
le territoire et échanger pour savoir
comment redynamiser les zones rurales
européenne la prochaine rencontre
transnationales aura lieu en suède en
septembre 2018